(dramatic music)
- It's so great to kind
of like get a moment
where you felt like you could still
have like a really fun theater experience,
I know it's not the way folks intended
but it was really great
to really sort of see
these characters back
and doing all this amazing stuff.
But why 1984, why the '80s,
why do you think we had
to set the story in this
particular time period?
- There were a bunch of reasons,
one of them was after
shooting the first movie
in 1917, World War I,
everything was gray and gloomy.
To be able to move on for the next story
where the environment is so
alive and so pop and colorful,
just felt like super great.
But on the philosophical level,
the '80s were the heights of everything,
of success and access.
And it was the time when people
didn't think about the repercussions
of what's going to happen.
And we felt like it had a
lot of resembles to nowadays.
- Yeah, I think it's like
the ostentatiousness of it.
If that's the word
- Exactly.
that I was like living for.
- And I can't say that
anyone is more ostentatious
than what Kristen is doing with Barbara,
it is just simply amazing
and they give her so much,
and I loved watching y'all go toe-to-toe,
as much as I liked y'all like
sort of having those like bonding moments.
But, I have to ask about the fight scenes.
So what was it like (chuckles)
fighting Kristen Wiig,
'cause y'all look like, I hate
to say you were having fun,
but it looked like you're having fun.
- We were having fun, it
was a lot of work too.
Patty really made a point about having
as minimum amount of CGI as possible,
which was great, but it just meant
that we had to do a lot of
the heavy lifting ourselves.
So we spent, both Kristen
and I, together and apart,
we spent so much time working out
and working with the stunt teams
learning the choreographies and rehearsing
and doing the wire work
and doing the water work.
It was like, it was a lot.
But working with Kristen
made the whole experience
much more delightful.
- What did you do?
(dramatic music)
- I was just saying the
Gal like it's so colorful,
it's just so audacious, and
she said, That's why you guys
wanted to do it in the 80s.
But I'm just curious for
you personally, like,
what is your connection to that timeframe?
'Cause I think everybody
approaches a decade differently.
So what is it personally identify to you?
- I came of age and, you know,
I was in junior high in the 80s,
and so I, well I was in high school too.
But I just remember it as,
from the point of view of a teenager,
it was so much fun, and
the movies were amazing,
everything was exciting, and
everything seemed possible.
I couldn't wait to go travel the world
and go to New York and all that stuff.
So, that's what I really
remember about it,
and I was excited to
capture, was that kind of
the world where everything
seems possible still.
And there really was that kind of naivety,
that this way of life would
ever stop being successful.
And so it was interesting
to take Wonder Woman
who's now seen World War I, World War II,
Vietnam, seen all of these things
and collide her with a
time of such opulence
and excess and naivety,
when she is not naive.
And so that was very
interesting as a character
and visually I just loved
that it was so different
from the first movie.
I got to see my, my Wonder Woman
that I grew up loving in Lynda Carter
in the right time for her
and so I loved that about it as well.
- Yeah, it definitely felt
like the Lynda Carter vibes,
the colorful vibes,
like all of the, it
felt like an 80s movie,
like a period piece almost,
like it very much felt like of that era.
And I, but I do have to
ask because it now fits
in the timeline differently.
Has Zack tapped you for any like
Snider cut, little nods back,
like I'm just curious if he's now like,
seen it and he's gonna
put some stuff in there.
- No, he hasn't, he has seen it.
He's seen the film.
But, I don't-
- Okay.
- I haven't seen the Snider
cut yet and what he's doing
but no, he didn't he
didn't require anything
to put this movie off.
(laughs)
- No, no, I know he doesn't need anything.
Folks are just gonna be
really happy to see it.
- Okay, I don't mean it
that way, you know, I just,
he didn't need me to
retrospectively, yeah, know nothing.
- Gotcha you.
No, no, it's great, though.
But it's in the canon now,
that's what's so great
about this is it sets up
this whole new timeline,
so I really do love that.
And then also we have to
ask about the recent news
and I just wanna know.
You probably can't tell us
anything but its history,
so we kinda know a little.
What can tell us about Cleopatra,
and why you guys are teaming
up this next time again?
- Cleopatra is such an interesting story,
but it's one of those stories
that's never been told,
really from her point of view.
It's only been told by the Romans
who hated her and killed her.
So when you really...
It's one of those, when you
start to look at the story,
you realize something very different
than you think was going on.
And she was just an epic,
legendary, powerful leader.
And so what an interesting story.
Gal is such an incredible
person to play it.
And so, that's such a,
it's a beautiful project.
- You know what, I'm ready to go.
(upbeat music)
- I think we can do better.
- Parachute pants?
- Yeah.
- Does everybody parachute now?
(rock music)